"The Batman" reviews are in – is the movie
another "Dark Knight?"
Or is it more of a lackluster night out?
"Oh, you're really not as smart as I thought
you were."
Matt Reeves' "The Batman" introduces us to
Robert Pattinson's version of the Dark Knight,
who Thrillist has described as an "eerie take
on the Caped Crusader."
The Beat proclaims the new movie is the first
"Batman" incarnation "to pick up Nolan's mantle
where others have failed before."
At this point, the film has already scored
a "Certified Fresh" rating on Rotten Tomatoes.
Of course, with bold statements comparing
the latest iteration of Gotham's savior to
the one Nolan gave us in a trilogy, verdicts
from the other end of the spectrum were bound
to appear.
Opinions are, after all, a lot like costumed
identities in Gotham City — everyone's got
to have one.
But just what could possibly get stuck in
the cowl of critics who didn't see this new
movie as anything special?
Well, by the sounds of things, it seems that
their issues have to do with similar traits
to the many, many Batman films that have come
before.
In a 1.5 out of 5 star review for The Washington
Post, writer Ann Hornaday said,
"'The Batman' [...] is a film that's as ponderous
as it is convoluted and, ultimately, devoid
of meaningful stakes."
She also describes it as, quote, "another
lugubrious, laboriously grim slog masquerading
as a fun comic book movie."
Naturally, considering the genre, the movie
is being compared to many superhero movies
that came before it – and for some reviewers,
it's coming up short.
Blake Howard of Dark Horizons deemed that
"The Batman" strains to live up to what's
come before.
In the very first line of the review, Howard
writes,
"'The Batman' is a needless collage of not
only better movies, but more egregiously of
better Batman movies as director/co-writer
Matt Reeves and co-writer Peter Craig create
an utterly inferior and infuriating vision
of the Dark Knight."
"If this continues, it won't be long before
you've nothing left."
One element that seems to be getting a lot
of attention for all the wrong reasons is
the film's runtime, which brushes up against
three hours.
This might not be an issue, had it not been
for the story, which to some felt overstuffed,
even with all of that time to let things play
out.
A review for Tilt Magazine described this
new take on the Bat as a, quote, "B-minus
serial killer thriller, one with a needlessly
convoluted plot, too many characters, unconvincing
twists, and a terrible villain."
That last point is particularly surprising,
considering that over reviews have singled
out Paul Dano's Riddler as a high point of
the movie.
The New York Post's Johnny Oleksinski has
nothing but bad love for the Bat as well,
making comparisons to the Nolan era of the
Caped Crusader's big screen outings.
He wrote,
"Director Matt Reeves' downer movie embraces
the realism of 'The Dark Knight' — the opposite
of Tim Burton's purple-hazed funhouse — only
without the payoff of excellent writing and
acting."
While it's always been an aim for Batman to
strike fear into the hearts of criminals and
villains, this movie is eliciting impatience
from reviewers.
As Oleksinski summed up,
"There's an unshakable feeling here of 'What's
the point?'
Not to mention the nearly three-hour length.
Holy runtime!"
"Selina – don't throw your life away."
For some reviewers, the movie's cast proved
incapable of elevating the material – including,
in some writers' opinions, Robert Pattinson
as Batman.
The Times' Kevin Maher wrote,
"The performances are as complex as the colour
palette (ie not very).
Pattinson, who has delivered so many thrilling
turns recently, struggles to elevate his antihero
beyond a pouty emo brat."
Meanwhile, Moira McDonald with The Seattle
Times said that Pattinson " isn't given the
opportunity to bring much to the role."
Instead, his "young, eerily pale and very
intense Bruce Wayne" is another apparent entry
in what she describes as, quote, "the mercifully
sparse brotherhood of Superheroes Who Are
Too Moody to Wash Their Hair."
"Whoa, take it easy, sweetheart!"
Of course, other reviewers were effusive about
the movie; your mileage may vary.
Maybe it's worth seeing the film for yourself
when "The Batman" arrives in theaters on March
4th.
Check out one of our newest videos right here!
Plus, even more Looper videos about "The Batman"
are coming soon.
Subscribe to our YouTube channel and hit the
bell so you don't miss a single one.